[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM SWAST: Hello.
I'm Tim Swast.
I'm an engineer on the Google
Developer Relation team.
I write code samples
and tutorials, mostly
focusing on Google's
big data products.
So speaking of data,
let's take a look at some.
It's a bunch of numbers.
Can you see any patterns here?
Probably not, because this
is only 10% of the data.
So let me bring it
all on one slide.
Now it should be really
clear what's going on.
Well, it's not clear to me.
That's because I'm a human.
I can't ingest raw numbers.
I need a human-friendly
visualization
to figure out what's going
on and make inferences
about my data.
The data that we're
going to see in this demo
is mostly going to
be from BigQuery.
BigQuery is a petabyte-scale,
server-less data warehouse.
It gives you
standard equal access
to very large scale data.
Now, if you store your data
in something like Cloud SQL,
you can still get the same
power of the BigQuery SQL engine
using BigQuery's
federated query feature.
And now, we've also launched
the Bigtable federated query
feature, so if you've got a
bunch of streaming IoT data
into Cloud Bigtable,
you can access that
through the same SQL
interface from BigQuery.
And we're also going
to see a little bit
of connecting visualization
tools to Cloud SQL as well.
I figure you don't want to
just look at random data,
so let's look at some
real world stuff today.
We're going to use Google's
public dataset program and just
a handful of data
sets from that--
some weather data, some
data from various US cities,
and the USA names database.
But there are many more
datasets available,
and Google's adding
more all the time.
And for the tools that
we're going to use,
we're going to see a bit
of Cloud Datalab, which
is a Python environment for
building visualizations,
and doing some machine
learning tasks.
We're going to build some
dashboards with Data Studio.
And no visualization talk
is complete without talking
about spreadsheets,
so we're going
to use Google Sheets
a little bit today.
And then Tableau is
going to come on stage
and demonstrate their
powerful visualization tool.
Google Cloud connects to many
other visualization tools
via our partner companies.
A few of them are listed here.
And many open source tools
let you connect easily
to Google Cloud.
You're going to see
a lot of code today.
I don't want you to worry too
much about understanding it,
because I'm going to zip
through it pretty fast.
I made a blog post here.
You can go to that link,
bit.ly/visualize-with-gcp,
and I've got links to all the
demos I've done with source
code.
So why are we
visualizing our data?
The big reason to
visualize your data
is you've got a problem
you want to solve.
So one problem that
a lot of people have
is how to name a child.
Now, that's a very
personal decision,
but I'm a geek so I
want to try to use
big data to help solve this.
The first thing to do when
you're building a visualization
is to build a
summary of the data.
It doesn't make sense to try
to see gigabytes and gigabytes
of data all in one plot.
We want to build a nice
summary and visualize that.
So the way we're going to
do that is with BigQuery.
So for our name
assignment task, we
might want to try to get a feel
for what names are out there
and how are they distributed.
So this query selects
the first letter
of all the names in
the USA names database
and counts how many names
start with that letter.
Now let's cut to the demo.
This is that same query,
but in the BigQuery UI.
I'm going to click this red
button here to run the query,
and that's going to
take a few seconds.
And once that
completes, we're going
to click this Save
to Google Sheets
button in the right corner.
And then we'll
click to view that.
It's opened a new tab, and
then once that loads up we're
going to see the results of
our query in a Google Sheet.
Now, I don't care too much
about the exact numbers.
What I really want is to get
a feel for the distribution,
so I'm going to
insert a new chart.
Google Sheets recommends, based
on the types of data it sees,
different visualizations.
In this case it's
suggesting a bar chart,
which is exactly what we want.
Let's insert that.
Now we can clearly see that
the letter J on the left
is by far the most popular
starting letter for names.
And then it trails
off slowly, eventually
getting down to the letter
U, which is so infrequently
used it doesn't even show up
as a bar on this bar chart.
So maybe if you're
going for a unique name,
pick one that starts
with the letter
U. Ursula or Ulysses might
be a good option there.
We have explored our data
by building a visualization.
And the great thing
about Google Sheets
is it's easy to share
it with your coworkers,
so they can see both
the results of the query
and the visualizations
you've built.
Now, there's a potential
problem with picking
a name that starts with the
letter U. I know I experienced
this in elementary school.
So you're back in
elementary school,
and you're lining up to
go outside for recess.
The teacher's going to
line you up alphabetically.
And it's really uncomfortable
being at the end of the line,
and it's also
equally uncomfortable
being at the
beginning of the line.
So I know growing up, I wanted
to be in that nice, comfortable
center spot.
So let's see if we can build a
visualization to help optimize
for that in our name.
So to summarize the
data, we're going
to run a different SQL query.
In this case, we're looking at
all the names in the dataset
and counting how many people
total have had that name.
And that might seem like a
lot of data-- and it is--
but it's a small enough set
that our visualization tools can
handle it and it lets us
filter it in different ways
after we've run
our initial query.
This is Cloud Datalab.
It's a Python/Jupiter
notebook environment,
and what that means
is it's built up
of these gray boxes
which are called cells.
So these cells have
Python code in them,
and you see they're
highlighted in gray right now.
That means I haven't
run them yet.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to click through
and hit the Shift
and Enter key on my
keyboard, and that's
going to run the code live.
So the first thing
that we're doing
is importing some libraries.
Those libraries might be
familiar to many Python
programmers.
We're just using
matplotlib, which
is very common for building
visualizations in Python,
and pandas for
doing our analysis
and also doing our
BigQuery query.
So our query completed.
And you see there's
about 30,000 rows here,
so let's build a chart of that.
This is called a Pareto chart.
It's basically a bar
chart, because you
can see the bars here very much
like the previous plot we saw.
But then there's this
extra line graph here,
and what that line
graph represents
is the cumulative total.
So, for example,
at the letter I,
you see it crosses the 40% mark.
That means 40% of names begin
with the letters A through I--
so anything at I or
appearing before it.
Now, what we're looking for is
that nice center spot, so we're
looking for where it
crosses the 50% mark, which
seems to be at about the letter
J. So let's zoom in on that.
So here's another Pareto plot,
this time with the first two
letters of the different
names, this time starting
with the letter J.
And we're looking
for that 50% mark
again, so we've got the
letters J, O. So maybe start
a name that begins with Jo.
So zoom in again, and, again,
look for that 50% mark line.
And we see it crosses at jor.
Now, for our final
visualization,
we're actually
going to do a table.
And the table is technically a
visualization, but in this case
it is the most appropriate one.
Because we're looking
for a specific name,
so we're looking for
that exact 50% mark,
right where it crosses.
And you see there's
some pretty close ties,
but Jordan is our
perfectly unbiased name.
If you pick the
name Jordan, you're
going to have the
best chance of being
at the center of those
lines in elementary school.
So that was a bit
silly, so let's get back
to some serious data.
This actually does
mean something.
This represents the last
10 years of weather data
from Austin, Texas.
So Austin's famous for many
things and many festivals,
but one of those is the Austin
City Limits Music Festival.
So this festival has been
going on for over 10 years,
and a few years ago
back in 2009 they
switched from being on
a weekend, primarily
in September, to a
weekend in October.
Now, my Austin friends have
many theories about this,
but the most common
one seems to be
it's really hot in
Austin in September,
especially for an outdoor
music festival where you're out
in the sun all day.
So my friends' hypothesis is
that the organizers switch
to October to beat the heat.
Now, that's a
great theory and it
seems to make some
intuitive sense,
but let's use some
big data and see
if this hypothesis is correct.
The first thing we're going
to do is build a summary,
so we're going to run
another BigQuery query.
This query selects data from
the NOAA weather public dataset.
So that data set is over 100
years of temperature data
from weather stations
across the world.
So the way we're going
to filter it down
is just select the Austin,
Texas, weather station
and limit to just the past
10 years of weather data.
Again, we're going to
use Datalab Notebook
and the same libraries,
pandas matplotlib.
And this query might
take a little bit
longer because it's a
slightly larger dataset,
but it's still pretty fast.
Now let's plot this data out.
Now, this is the
exact same set of data
that you saw in that slide,
but it should be a lot clearer,
the patterns here.
So I've taken 10 years
of data, and then I've
overlaid them on
top of each other
so that you can see
the seasonal changes.
So the x-axis here is
the day of the year,
and the y-axis is the
temperature in Fahrenheit.
And red means the
high temperature
for the day, blues
the low temperature,
and gray is the average
temperature for the day.
So one thing you can
definitely see here
is it's a lot hotter in
summer, as we'd expect,
and actually the variance
between temperatures
is a lot lower in the summer
months versus the winter
months.
They really change throughout
the days in the winter.
But this graph doesn't
answer our question.
What we want to know is
where music festivals
lie on this line.
Let's see that.
I've zoomed in a little bit.
On the left is one
of the music festival
weekends that happened in
September, and on the right
the blue line is one
of the music festivals
that happened in October.
So we can definitely see
a downward trend here.
There's about five degrees
difference between October
and September and
the high temperatures
and low temperatures,
but five degrees
is not a big difference.
So maybe that's not
the primary reason
the organizers picked
October as the month.
One thing about choosing
October is the first year
that the Austin City Limits
Music Festival was in October,
there were torrential
downpours all weekend.
So this outdoor music festival
was a really muddy mess,
and they had spread
composts out on the lawn
before and so it
smelled really bad, too.
So maybe if you're
picking an ideal weekend
based on the weather for
your outdoor music festival,
maybe pick it on more than
just the temperature data.
So speaking of Austin, I used to
live there for about five years
or so.
And one of the problems
I encountered, and wish
I had a visualization
to help me solve,
was choosing where to live.
I'm a big public transit nerd.
I like to take the bus and
the light rail whenever I can.
Even in Austin where
it's 100 degrees out
and I'm outside in the hot
sun, I'll still take the bus.
So maybe my ideal spot would
be close to a reliable public
transit station.
The other thing about
living in Austin
is you learn to love the taco.
You end up eating tacos
every meal of the day,
but especially breakfast.
So my ideal spot
would be somewhere
that's both close
to reliable transit
but also close to some of
my favorite taco shops.
So let's build a visualization
to help us solve this problem.
We're going to summarize
the data again,
again with BigQuery.
This time we're going
to query a dataset
called cap metrics,
which was uploaded
by a member of the Open Data
community, Sean Cascketta
to a public BigQuery dataset.
And this data includes
bus tracking data--
so times and locations of all
the buses, as well as the bus
stops.
So what I'm selecting
here is whenever
a bus is at a bus stop, I want
to know is that bus on schedule
or off schedule, because I'm
using that as my measure of how
reliable the buses are.
I'd rather the bus be on
schedule than off schedule.
So back to the demo.
This is another notebook, and
this is more Python code here.
I'm using pandas and matplotlib,
but a few other libraries here
to work with geographic data.
And also, I uploaded
the query results
to a Cloud SQL
postgres instance.
The reason I did that is because
the postgres instance supports
the PostGIS extension,
which allows me
to do GIS queries against it.
In this case, I've got
my bus tracking data,
and I also added a table
for my favorite taco shops.
So I'm selecting the distance to
the closest taco shop via SQL.
So the query is finished.
Let's build a plot of this.
This is called a
Voronoi diagram.
It gives you an idea of
where the bus stops are--
that's these blue dots here--
but also the area
served by that bus stop.
These blue dots are
surrounded each by a polygon.
Any point within that
area, the nearest bus stop
is the blue circle
contained within it.
Now, I've plotted this
latitude-longitude data
on just a regular xy
plane, and that's not
quite the right thing to do.
So let's plot it out
on a map instead.
So I'm going to convert this
Voronoi diagram into Go-JSON,
and then I'm going
to plot it out using
a library called leaflet.
So here's all our bus stop
areas plotted out on a map.
So we can see the
different areas
served by the bus stops
overlaid on the map of Austin.
This doesn't quite
answer our question,
so let me color it in
based on the reliability
of the buses in those stations.
So now we can see the dark
purple areas are where
the buses are not so reliable.
They're off-schedule on
average by quite a bit,
and the lighter areas are
where the public transit is
pretty reliable and they're
on schedule most of the time.
So that's great.
We could use this to
find an apartment,
but it doesn't solve
my taco problem.
So let's combine the taco
table with this data set.
So now I've overlaid
where all my favorite taco
shops are, and then
I've colored it
in not only by the public
transit reliability,
but also the proximity
to a taco shop.
So the light areas are the
areas that have reliable transit
and are close to a taco
shop, and the darker areas
are either not reliable or far
away from a taco shop or both.
So panning around here, we
can see a few possible choices
if we want to live
on the south side.
I happen to know this is
William Canyon Road down here,
and it's by Torchy's Tacos.
If we want to live
on the east side,
there's not too many
choices, but we've
got a little spot of white here
by the Plaza Saltillo light
rail station and El Chilito.
Or if we want to live
on the north side,
there's a nice spot up
here across Torchy's Tacos
on Burnet Road.
So we found the
perfect place to live.
It's got reliable public transit
and proximity to delicious
tacos.
So let's imagine for a minute
that you're a data scientist
and you're working for the
public transit company.
So you just saw my
talk and you want
to cut down on the number
of those purple areas.
So it's your job to help keep
these buses running on time.
So you're going to do the
same kinds of analysis
that we just saw,
but eventually you're
going to want to share your
work with one of your coworkers.
So one way to do that
is to take a screenshot
of your visualization
and then send it off
in an email to your coworker.
Now, that works fine.
They're going to see the
exact same image you saw,
but there's a problem with that.
Buses move around.
So by the time your coworker
gets to that email an hour
later, the problem
will have evolved.
So ideally we'd have
a live dashboard that
shows not the data an hour
ago, but the data as it
is right now, and we're going
to use Data Studio to build
a dashboard like that.
Data Studio allows you
to connect to BigQuery,
as we've seen in the other
visualizations in this talk.
But it also supports Google
Analytics and many other data
sources.
In this case, we're going
to use a BigQuery query.
So this query is very similar
to the previous one we saw.
I'm still looking at
how far off-schedule
the buses are on average,
but this time I'm
splitting up by the day of the
week and the hour of the day
because I want to see how the
problem changes over time.
Cutting to the demo, I built
this Data Studio dashboard.
So I used Data Studio's
filtering mechanism
to build seven
different graphs here,
each showing a different
day of the week.
And then I've got a
line graph for each one.
The x-axis is the
time of the day,
and the y-axis is how far
off-schedule are the buses
on average for that hour.
So you can see the buses
start off on time--
which makes sense; they've
just started their route--
and then they get more
and more off-schedule
throughout the day.
In the afternoon, they
catch up a little bit,
but then rush hour hits and
they get way out of whack.
So the great thing
about Data Studio
is this Share button up here.
You can click that.
It gives you a link.
You can send that
off to your coworker,
and then when they
load this page up
it's going to rerun
that query and they'll
see a life view of the data.
And if you want their help
building this dashboard-- maybe
you want them to add some
new visualizations to it--
you can give them
edit access, just
like you would a Google Doc.
Now, I've only used line
graphs in this dashboard,
but Data Studio also supports
bar charts, geographic maps,
scatter charts, all the
visualizations we saw today
and more.
Data Studio's great for
this sharing use case.
It's not the tool I'd
use for the analysis
part, the exploration
phase, figuring out
what transformations and
I want to make to the data
and how I want to visualize it.
For that, I like to
use those notebooks.
It's really handy to be
able to run some Python
code to grab some data,
filter it in a bunch of ways,
and try out different
visualizations.
So speaking of
code, again, here's
the link to the
blog post in case
you forgot it and you
want to look up the code I
used to build these demos.
But if you're not a coder,
there's another option,
and that's Tableau.
Tableau is a powerful
visualization and analysis
tool--
no coding skills required.
And to show you
more about that, let
me introduce Vaidy
Krishnan who's
going to come to
stage and show you
how GCP customers are using
Tableau to gain insights
about their big data.
VAIDY KRISHNAN: Thank you.
So my name is Vaidy.
I lead partnerships for Tableau.
So my job at Tableau is to
work with Google and all
the other technology
partners we collaborate with
and that help our customers be
more successful with Tableau.
And today, I'm going
to talk to you about,
first of all, how Tableau
integrates with the Google
platform, why customers choose
Google, why customers choose
Tableau and why.
The joint value
that we provide is
a win for both of us
and our customers.
Then I'm going to get into
some best practices for using
BigQuery and Tableau together.
But before that, I just want
to do a quick show of hands.
How many are familiar with
what Tableau is or are already
using Tableau?
So that's great.
So it seems like everyone has
had a chance to experience
Tableau or are already using
it, but I'm sure many of you
have sometimes struggled
with performance
and haven't quite understood
how to work with that.
And we're going to talk
about some best practices.
And before I will end, I'll
just get into a quick demo
where we'll connect to a billion
rows' worth of New York City
taxi data.
And I'll talk about some big
customers wins we've had,
including several that were
featured on the keynote stage
yesterday.
So here's what the
Google Tableau data
platform looks like.
So Tableau is just the top
layer of a very deep stack
that most customers use
to organize and analyze
information inside
their enterprises.
So the way this works in most
cases, you have some raw data.
This could be coming from
sensors, this could be sales,
this could be marketing data.
It goes into Google
Cloud Storage.
Then it flows into one of
many different databases,
all of which Tableau offers
direct native connectivity to.
So we're talking Cloud SQL.
All the marketing website data
goes into Google Analytics,
Google Sheets, Google BigQuery.
We'll soon offer direct
connectivity to Google Bigtable
and to Cloud Dataproc, which
is Google's Hadoop as a service
platform.
Now, many of you
might ask, well,
what is native connectivity?
So native connectivity--
essentially,
Tableau and Google
working together
to make sure our connection
is tuned for performance
and makes full use of
the Tableau feature set.
When we just connect via ODBC,
it's not always optimized,
so both our engineers
have been hard at work
to make sure this
integration is performing
and works great
for our customers.
So we're talking about
Google BigQuery today.
I want to spend a
couple of moments just
to emphasize why our customers
like Google BigQuery.
And I'm not going
to dwell on this
because I'm sure many
of you have attended
several other sessions
that cover this,
but what I liked the
most about this slide
is GBQ's doing away with all
the traditional issues you faced
with data warehouses
on the left-hand side.
You don't have to design,
build, and manage servers.
You don't have to forecast
capacity, and when
you do that there's typically
a lot of costs associated
with it, which creates
a barrier to entry.
With Google BigQuery, you have
a server-less architecture,
so it's completely abstracted
out from the customer.
You can automatically
scale storage up and down,
based as your needs
and your usage grow.
And totality-- what this means
is the customer gets agility.
They don't have to
necessarily invest
upfront and deal with the
risk of just letting their--
they don't have to deal
with a lot of risks.
So as with any cloud
platform you have out there,
Google BigQuery
makes sure that they
don't have to invest
time in capex,
and most is opex and
scalable and agile.
So let's talk about some
of the common problems
you face with analyzing data.
Well, first is, as with
many legacy BU products--
and, in fact, a
surprising number
of new vendors, especially
in the data discovery space--
they make you write
code to connect to data.
Which is great for a DBA or
someone who is a developer,
but if you're a business
user or someone who
is close to the action
that come out of his work
and who knows the
data, you don't
have to spend time doing that.
Now, once you're able
to connect to data,
it's typically very
hard to create a vis.
You need to know
what questions you're
going to ask before
you analyze it,
but that's not how
data exploration works.
90% of the time I just
have a billion rows,
and I don't even know
what question to ask.
I need to just explore away
and let that data guide what
that question should be.
So imagine a platform
that's asking
you to click on a
bunch of wizards
or choose a chart type
even before you've
asked that question.
We wanted to disrupt
that experience,
and I'll talk about how
Tableau solves that.
And finally, once you've created
something, you have to share--
and Tim alluded to
this a little earlier--
that work with the rest
of your organization.
This could be internally,
with stakeholders or clients,
to make sure that that
analysis is acted on.
And again, that has
typically not been easy
in traditional BI platforms.
So how can Tableau help?
Well, first of all, you can
connect to all the Google data
sources I talked about and
a whole slew of other data
sources in a minute.
And I firmly believe that
across most organizations,
not all your data
rests in one place.
So you may have a
ton of data in GBQ,
but you have data in Salesforce,
you have data in Marketo.
You still have some of
those old spreadsheets
that some of your
teams may be continuing
to update on an
ongoing basis that you
want to bring into an analysis.
We allow you to bring all
those data sources together,
and we are not just
a visualization tool.
So I know when we
started out back
in 2003, the first
couple of years
the market saw us as a shiny
new toy, but over the years
we've expanded our capabilities.
We're now proud to be an
enterprise-ready, mission
critical platform
that allows people not
just to analyze
and explore data,
but to share, govern, and
collaborate and distribute it
in a way that makes
people feel empowered.
And IT can also
participate now in driving
the analytics direction
of organizations.
So your business
users are governed
without feeling that
they are being governed,
and IT is now able to
focus all this time
on high-level security
and data management tasks.
So how do Tableau and
Google work together?
Again, it comes down to three
things-- speed and agility.
We deploy on the
Google Cloud engine.
You can connect in minutes,
start analyzing data
right away.
GCP offered scale and agility.
There's no guessing
capacity issues.
You don't have to
forecast in advance.
Scale up and down as you need.
And Tableau works with all kinds
of data and unlimited amounts,
and I'll illustrate that in a
demonstration in a little bit.
And of course, there's
TCO, which both of us
are really great at.
Ours has been ranked the lowest
among all the major BI vendors,
and GCP can be up to 40%
cheaper than cloud competitors.
So what are some best practices
for Tableau and BigQuery
together?
Again, I'm not going to
dwell on all of these,
but there's a few
ones that I would
like to just double-click on.
And so the top half is
all the best practices
that have to deal
with Google BigQuery.
So first of all, when
a visualization is not
performing, 50% of the
time-- or I would say 70%,
75% of the time--
you haven't tuned
your data source well.
It's a data source that
performs against a data source,
I always like to
tell my customers.
If your SQL against a data
source is taking 50 seconds,
Tableau cannot make
that 40 seconds.
So you always have to start
with the data source first.
So what do you do?
Avoid select star.
Why is that?
Because Google BigQuery
is a columnar store,
so what that means
is every column
is in a different
physical block.
So if you choose your columns
and not do select stars,
queries are going to
be more performant.
Denormalization is
your best friend.
So Google BigQuery
is great at joins,
but if you're able to pre-join
and flatten out your structures
and essentially trade your
storage for compute resources,
well, obviously you're going
to be paying more for storage
but paying a lot
less for compute.
And I think that's a
very effective trade-off.
Your query's are going
to come back faster.
So always denormalize
your tables.
And actually, this works
for Tableau as well.
We like denormalized
structures, because it
helps us fire that analytical
query a lot better.
Leverage natural partitioning
or use explicit charting.
So again, the point
we're trying to make
is avoid full table scans and
leverage natural partitioning,
which is usually your
record create date.
So if you have a bunch
of tables and you
have one table for each
date, you can use that.
Or make sure you're
using some sort of filter
to not scan everything and
just scan what you need.
On the Tableau side,
again, I have seen billions
of rows worth of data--
people experience 20x
performance improvements
over several billions
of rows of data
just because they had a solid
indexing and partitioning
strategy.
Avoid too many filters.
Avoid large dataset to
second dataset blending.
The thing about Tableau
is just because its easy,
it allows people to
do a lot of things.
And just because you
can do it doesn't
mean you should, so avoid that.
And stay away from
having a large number
of schemas and columns.
It's always good
to know in advance
or try to figure out what
are the columns you want
to explore, versus what's junk.
And only connect to
what you know for sure
you're going to use.
So with that, let's get
into a really quick demo.
Here I am connected
to Tableau desktop.
So this is what an analyst would
use to create visualizations.
So this is the analyst, and I
am going to go ahead and connect
to Google BigQuery instance.
And I want to highlight some
of the improvements we've
made recently in
support of some features
that the Google
BigQuery team developed.
The first thing is, since
GBQ charges for storage
and computes
separately, you can now
use the billing project
feature to point
or to charge a certain project.
So imagine you have a bunch
of stakeholders or clients.
You can actually
charge all the queries
to that one project, which
saves a lot of headache
down the road.
The second thing is we
have now the ability
to write custom SQL, which
can be validated right away.
Why would you want
to write custom SQL?
A bunch of different reasons.
Sometimes, for
instance, you might
want to use a native
Google BigQuery function.
Let's say you want to use
the wildcard function.
How many of you
are aware of that,
where you can actually do
select star from table dot star?
So if you want to do
something like that,
you can leverage custom SQL.
Also, we have
added a little flag
that lets you control whether
you want to send a legacy SQL
or standard SQL.
So GBQ has now announced
support for standard SQL,
which is ANSI SQL compliant.
But there are
several customers who
have views that have all
been written in legacy SQL.
So when that's the
case, you obviously
want to send legacy SQL,
and we give you that option.
So let's go ahead
and do some analysis.
So here I am going to pull--
I think it's about six or seven
years worth of New York City
taxi data all downloaded
from the NYC.gov website
and staged into Google
query, and I'm going
to start asking some questions.
The first thing I
want to know is, well,
how many rows there are.
And let's do that.
It looks like there's
about a little
in excess of a billion rows.
And this is a perfect
example of an analysis
I'm going to do where I
don't even know what to ask.
Well, I'm just going
to explore away.
So first thing I want
to know is, well,
how have these number of
records trended over time?
So how about I look at this
by the pickup date time.
And I'm going to
look at this by year.
Well, that's kind of nice.
What if I want to look at
it by quarter or month?
Maybe I want to express this
a little bit differently
as a bar.
The other question
I might want to ask
is, well, how have the
volumes of rides changed
over time by payment type?
So that's one dimension
that I see in the data
I have, so I can
bring that to color.
And it's going to
fire that query again.
And hopefully, it
comes back in a bit.
Now, while that
happens, let me also
tell you that Tableau takes a
hybrid approach towards data.
So we allow our customers
to connect live,
but customers are
always encouraged
to use our Tableau data
extract if they only
want a snapshot in time.
So they can always
bring data into memory,
and we have a lot
of customers who
may have trillions of records.
But to prove a
concept, they just
need data for the
last couple of years.
And you can use a Tableau
data extract to do that,
so that's nice.
And what this is doing is
it's highlighting a problem
that we see with a lot of
data, which is dirty data.
So here I have cash
transactions being represented
as multiple categories.
I might want to just go
ahead and club them as one,
so I'm going to do
that right here.
And when I do that, it
doesn't change the source.
All it's doing is it's
changing the metadata.
So now we will have
a new payment group
created when that happens.
I'm going to go ahead and
club all the credit card
transactions as one as well.
So let's do that.
They're grouping
that all into one.
And I'm going to keep the
disputed transactions, too.
So, in fact, I think it might
be useful to club that, too,
because that is something that
I might want to analyze further.
So not surprisingly, if you
look at the data from 2009
through '15, the proportion
of credit card transactions
is increasing, and it's
not all that surprising.
But if you wanted to make
the case a lot better,
you could also add a
little table calculation
and express this result
as a percentage of total.
So that just makes it
clearer, a lot nicer.
What I can also do now is ask a
couple of different questions.
Maybe I want to look at just
the disputed transactions.
Maybe I want to know when
do all these disputed
transactions happen and
where do these happen
and does that tell
me something about,
as a cabbie, what are some areas
that I might want to avoid.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and say, Keep Only,
and I'm going to clear
this table calculation.
And I'm going to go ahead
and duplicate the sheet,
and now I'm going to try to
express this data a little bit
differently.
Maybe I want to look at the
same information by hour.
Again, nothing
surprising-- not a ton
of rides happening in the
wee hours of the morning,
but volumes grow as you
get later in the day.
The next question
is, well, can I
hone in on certain neighborhoods
or certain boroughs
within New York where all
these disputes are happening
the wee hours of the morning?
So for that, I am going
to represent this data
geographically.
So let's look at my
latitudes and longitude data.
That's what I wanted.
So there's my latitude, and
let's bring in my longitudes
here.
And Tableau has
automatically, by the way,
geocoded this information,
so it recognizes
well-described addresses, it
recognizes boroughs in New
York, it recognizes zip codes.
But if you don't
have that, you can
use a whole range of
geocoding resources
to bring latitudes
and longitudes
and actually have
them inside Tableau.
But now you see that
there's some junk in here.
I mean, some of
those rides have been
coded as happening in
Africa and Antarctica,
and obviously I don't want that.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and hone in on just those rides
that are coded correctly.
And that's a lot of rides, so
why don't we focus in and just
clean this up a little bit.
And I can change the
map layer as well.
That's nicer.
And I can change the opacity,
just so it's nicer to look at.
And now I can bring this
all into a dashboard
and actually connect
these different views.
I don't need that.
I can go ahead and make
sure it's laid out right,
and I can enable action filters.
And with that, I can use one
view to filter the other.
So obviously, we
see here there is
a lot of activity
around LaGuardia,
JFK, some busy thoroughfares
around Brooklyn
and Williamsburg.
And Midtown is
always crazy, even
in the wee hours of the morning.
So again, just a very quick
illustration of how all of this
comes together.
And, again, this was done
off of a billion rows.
So how are customers leveraging
Tableau and BigQuery together?
So here's three
different examples.
We're a fairly
horizontal platform.
We have customers across
all verticals using Tableau.
We're in about 95% of the
Fortune 500 companies.
But the three I
want to highlight
are one, which is Kabam--
very small gaming
company, lots of data.
They've had a relationship
with Google for years,
and they're asking questions
around their gaming data.
They want to know
user behavior, where
do people get stuck,
how do I design
the game so people spend more.
These are the kinds of
questions they're asking.
You have University
of Colorado at Denver,
and they just came out
with a press release today.
They're bringing
in their EHR data,
combining with patient
data and environment data,
to deliver
personalized medicine.
And of course, I'm not going
to talk about Home Depot.
You guys heard from them on
the keynote stage yesterday.
So with that, just
before I end, here
are some resources for you guys
on how the two platforms work
together.
If you have some
product-related questions,
please feel free
to reach out to me.
And if you want
to just try this,
just go ahead and download
a trial of Tableau
and a trial of Google BigQuery.
Connect the two.
There's a whole bunch
of public data sources
out there that Tim
pointed you guys to.
All that New York data
is available on the web.
There's some Medicare data,
and you can explore them
to your heart's content.
Also, check out the white paper.
I may or may not
have talked about it,
but all the best
practices that I covered
have been detailed
in the white paper.
And there's a lot of examples in
there as well for those of you
who are existing customers
and have been using the two
platforms together for years.
TIM SWAST: So if you want to
see more about Data Studio,
there was a talk
yesterday about that,
an the recording's already up.
There's a couple of
talks about BigQuery.
You can check those out.
And there's a great
talk by Philippe
about the Public
Dataset program,
so I recommend you go to those.
And then if you want to
try any of these firsthand,
you can go to these code labs.
This is the URL for
the Google Qwiklabs.
There's a couple
related ones there.
You can try out BigQuery with
the Wikipedia public dataset,
and you can try out Datalab
and some of the Cloud ML Engine
features that are tucked
into that that I didn't quite
get to today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]